[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الاردن تصل الان الى قصر الزهران وتتجه
الان عبر الممر المعدل
لسلام على عبد الله الثاني وكذلك الملك
رانيا صور تظهر احتفال ما هي من كل مكان
زميلنا عماد تحدث ايضا على ان كل شوارع
العاصمه الاردنيه عمان تحديدا لانه زينه
وكذلك هناك لافتات كثيره منتشره على جوانب
هذه الشوارع وفرحه كبيره تعم ايضا اوساط
الاردنيين هذه والده الملك الاردني وكذلك
منى الحسين وكذلك شقيقه الملك ايضا
نشاهد استقبال الملك
وايضا ملكه رانيا لهم
الان
الاحتفال الذي تقيمه الاردن
باحتفالا واحتفاء
بعملي العهد الملك الامير الحسين بن عبد
الله الثاني في حفل الزواج يعني كانت
الاستعدادات والتحضيرات اخذت يعني اياما
خلال الفتره السابقه
لم المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات